معنى الان في الاستديو روبرت مالي المبعوث
الامريكي الخاص لايران سيد مالي اهلا بك
معنا في الاستديو هنا في الدوحه وابدا
ربما بسؤالك عن تعليق على هذا الرد
الايراني
طريقه عمل ايران عندما يعبر المجتمع
الدولي عن مخاوف حقيقيه بشان برنامجهم
النووي وعن انهم ليسوا شفافين وهم يردون
بالتصعيد وهذا هو المنهج الخاطئ بالضبط
ونعمل ان لا يقوم باي شيء حتى اكثر
استفزاجا ولكن رغم هذا علينا ان همم نراقب
بحذر الخطوات التي سوف يتخذونها
ماذا تتوقع ان يكون تاثير هذا الموقف الان
على المفاوضات
ناس كثير
لم يكن هناك مفاوضات حقيقيه على مدى شهرين
ونصف ذلك لاننا اقتربنا من اتفاقيه كل
المشاركين وافقوا على النص وضعه الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الطاوله باستثناء في اللحظه
الاخيره ايران قررت بانها سوف تضع مطالب
جديده وهي لا علاقه لها
بالمفاوضات النوويه كما تم تحديدها وهذا
جعلنا نتراجع على مدى شهرين ونصف ولم نكن
نستطيع ان نركز على المفاوضات بل نركز على
اشياء اخرى القمع والاحتجاجات والقمع
الوحشي في ايران وان ايران الان تساعده
روسيا في حرب العدوانيه ضد اوكرا باذن
المفاوضات كانت عالقه على مدى شهرين ونصف
شهر
الذي دفع ايران لذلك رغم ان اكثر من طرف
يقول انا من مصلحه ايران ان يتم التوقيع
وانت تسير المفاوضات
عليك ان تسالي ايران ما هو منطقها نحن
نتخذ موقفا نحن نؤمن بالخيار الديبلوماسي
لمنع ايران من الحصول على اسلحه نوويه
واذا كان جاهزه للسير في هذا الخير نحن
سنرد ونتخذ الخطوات اللازمه وايران ايضا
تقوم زعزعه الاستقرار في المنطقه وتطهيد
شعبها اذا فالبابلوماسيه مفتوح ولكننا لن
ننتظر بل سوف نركز على المصالح الدوليه
فيما يسير الوقت قدما ايران تعتبر ان ما
قدم
غير صحيح غير دقيق ما مدى كلكم من دقه
الوثائق التي استندت اليها الوكاله ومن ثم
همم ما تقيمكم بهذا الرد
الاسكندريه
هي منظمه مستقل
مهنيه ولا احد يتحلى بالموضوعيه ينتقدها
ولكن ايران هي التي مازالت تختبء ولا تقدم
الاعجابات الاساسيه فالوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه هي تريد ان تضمن بان كل
المواد النوويه معروفه وهم يعرفون مكانها
ولم يتم تحويلها ايران ترفض ان تقدم اجوبه
اساسيه على مدى اعوام الى الان لذلك الرد
من الوكاله الدوليه الى الطاقه الذريه
طبيعي وردنا واعضاء اخرون في المجتمع
الدولي هو معظم مجلس الحكام في لوكارد قال
ان ايران عليها ان تتعاون بشفافيه تامه مع
هذه المنظمه المستقله واذا ايران اختارت
التصعيد ردا على ذلك فهذا سوف يجعلها تعزل
نفسها اكثر واكثر عن بقيه العالم
مالي انت تتحدث عن استقلاليه الوكاله ولكن
ايران تجادل بهذه الاستقلاليه تعتبر ان
زياره كروستي الى اسرائيل قبل ليس
الاجتماع الاخير لمحافظه الوكاله وانما
الاجتماع السابق ربما يدل على ان الوكاله
تميل الى طرف يقول صراحه انه لا يريد لهذه
المفردات ان تتقدم ولا يؤمن بان ايران
فعلا جد في همم مشوارها النووي
والتزاماتها اتجاه الغرب
بس دلوقتي
يتجول حول العالم
على الصعيد الدولي وجعله استنتاجاته واضحه
يمكن للجميع ان ينظر اليها ولا هنا صعوبه
هناك في هذا اذا ايران رفضت فان تقدم
الاجوبه بشان وجود مواد وجزيئات نوويه في
بعض المواقع كل ما عليه وان تكون شفافه هي
رفضت ان تجيب عن اسئله اساسيه
لذلك اي دوله في العالم تتعرض الى نفس
المعامله من الوكاله الدوليه الى طاقه
ايران طالما هي لم تجب عن هذه الاسئله في
الوكاله سوف تستمر بالتحقيق فقط الولايات
المتحده بل هناك اغلبيه الدول في المنطقه
ومجلس الحكام ايضا معظمهم اتخذوا ذات
القرار بالنسبه
ان تقدم اجوبه واضحه للوكاله التي تقوم
بتوجيه هذه الاسئله هذا الامر لا يجب ان
يكون صعبا على ايران اذا ما ارادت ان
تتعاون ولكن في ظل هذا الموقف كيف ترى
الخطوه القادمه كيف ترى مستقبل مفاضله
باب الدفلوسي مفتوح الان لوقت طويل وما
زال مفتوح ولكن الان مرت عامان من
النفاوضات وفي اكثر من مناسبه كنا مغتربين
من اتفاقيه وايران في اللحظه الاخيره وضعت
مطالب هم عليهم ان يقرر وما يريدون خلال
ذلك سوف نستمر التركيز على الامور التي في
جوهره المصالح
ان ينتهي في 2025 لم يبقى الكثير هل
بالنسبه لكم انه يستحق كل هذا العناء في
هذه الفتره
ما هو الجهود هو ان نتاكد بين ايران لن
تحصل على سلاح النووي وسوف نفعل هذا
ونتاكت من هذا المفاوضات والدبلوماسيه اذا
ما نجحت فان ادوات اخرى اذا ما تطلب الامر
ذلك